[Musique]
naples a christmas est ok
champion oui tanguy ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qu'on fait il m'a quitté
j'aimerais c'est toute ma vie qui
s'écoule bien puis surtout chaud
excusez moi je me sens pas très bien
je crois que je vais me coucher connais
tu étais parti couché hier soir mais bon
on m'a appelée et elle a insisté insisté
pour que je le rejoins dans un bar c'est
nul pascal 6h du matin exactement il va
mieux beaucoup mieux que ce qu'il
prétend aborder cet appartement il a
retrouvé lui je crois même que je le
préfère à l'ancien qu'est ce que c'est
d'après toi
je suis désolé je voulais pas des anges
et oui bon je veux c'est pas un problème
tu as raison en transférant j'ai dit oui
le temps passe mais après une décision
ou arthur c'est comme un deuil ça durera
non parce que tu cours tu restes ici
elles n'ont donc eu les il aurait pu
l'essentiel c'est qu'il dégage
[Musique]